two of the three remaining hostages were
killed and they were shot by friendly
fire that was the first time that i'd
worked anything where people had gotten
killed
former fbi kidnapping negotiator
best-selling co-author of the founder
and principal of the black swan group
i'm chris voss how important is it
generally in negotiations to
listen whether it's business or law
enforcement if i take the time to to
really hear somebody out in our first
deal then every deal after that will
come to me faster
it's critical i'm so compelled to ask
you like what is the cost that we don't
get to see of your job you know you get
you get really wrapped up in your work
and i think you tend to become
distant
in your personal life the closer you are
to someone
sometimes
you just it's really harder for you to
see things from their perspective the
truth sometimes is a knife to the heart
right
like you go through a traumatic event
are you traumatized by it then never
recover or is there post-traumatic
stress growth where you took that and
decided to be better than you ever were
before because you never
want to let that happen again
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
direva ceo usa edition i hope nobody's
listening but if you are
then please keep this yourself
[Music]
chris
you've lived a
extraordinary life for many many reasons
which i'm sure we're going to go into
but um
i guess my first question is
what do i need to know about your
upbringing your early years if i am to
understand the man you are today
i think really that my father just
required that that we work hard and then
we figure stuff out like my father was
an entrepreneur
and then no matter how old you are even
i started working for him probably when
i was about 11 but the downside of
working for a guy that would never ask
you to do anything he wouldn't do
himself
if there is anything that he wouldn't do
himself just because it needed to be
done
then like you get asked to figure out
some crazy stuff
like you know a middle-class
entrepreneur you know
blue collar you know guy and i remember
i think it was about 11.
he decided he wanted a new garage in the
backyard and we had to get rid of the
old garage and
you know he handed me and my 13 year old
sister crowbars and said go out and tear
down the old garage
he just kind of
you know he's got to figure stuff out
and so i really grew up in an
environment of working really hard
it he never preached this ethics but we
were you know very ethical you know
honest hard working
and figure stuff out which is
if that's your attitude
there isn't that much you can't do
and that was kind of drilled into me at
an early age figured out work hard be
honest
so if i hit fast forward on your on your
life from that point and i go into your
days and the the swat team for the fbi
right
how long were you working in the swat
team with the fbi
uh i was i was technically a member of
the swat team for about a year and then
you know i was in on a pittsburgh fbi it
was on that swat team
and then i got transferred to new york
and i decided to try out for
the fbi's equivalent of the navy seals
the fbi's hostage rescue team
and so i tried out for that team and i
re-injured my knee
so i wasn't i never technically made
that team nor when i was in new york was
i on the new york swat team but i had
been on the swat team in
pittsburgh for about a year
you ended uni during training
yeah you know it was originally
uh toured up originally in college and
my view is you know the worst things
that have happened to me i've always led
the better stuff i would never become a
hostage negotiator if i hadn't torn on
my knee
and so you know then when i was trying
out for the hostage rescue team then i
re-injured it
and uh
i went went to a doctor to have it
rebuilt for a second time
[Music]
and at that point in time i thought well
i don't know how many times they could
put humpty dumpty back together
so i love crisis response because you
got to make a decision i've been very
much a decision-oriented guy you know
president kennedy talks about the
dangers of comfortable inaction i've
always hated that
so you know i wanted to stay involved in
crisis response we had hostage
negotiators
my son and i like to joke that one of
the voss family models is how hard can
it be
and i remember thinking how could it be
you know they talk
talk to terrorists i talk every day i
can talk to a terrorist
when you um when you injured your knee
and you you're thinking about what to do
with your life i i read that you
had a chat with a lady um about options
and she basically rejected you and said
yeah said go away
who is she
uh
she was the head of the hostage
negotiation team for fbi new york
she was on uh one of the terrorism
squads close to mine
and i knew she was in charge of the
program
and
you know i thought
you know the willingness to learn was
adequate
and so you know i sought her out to
express my interest and kind of
presented myself like ta-da here i am
i'm wonderful look at me
i'm willing to learn
and she was just like go away everybody
wants to do this it sounds cool
everybody wants a t-shirt
she asked me about you know any previous
experience or credentials i had i didn't
have any
one after another i was like nope nope
no education no background no experience
no no that's none of this none of this
and finally she just said like no you
can't do it
stop bothering me
it was like
got to be something i could do you know
i've always kind of been proactive
i didn't know i was there's a theory
that i uh principal that we operate on
now which is
never ask advice from somebody wouldn't
trade places with
or never take direction from somebody
who hasn't been where you're going
i just thought it made sense to go to
the right person and ask
which is kind of how i got in the fb in
the first place
and i said there's got to be something i
could do what is it she said you know
what there is go volunteer on a suicide
hotline
but until you've done that
don't bother me
and it just seemed really obvious to me
okay you know this is somebody who knows
i'll do it and that's how i got in the
fbi really
and so i went and did it and i went back
to and i said you know
i i've been volunteering a suicide
hotline for the last five months and
she's like
what she was shocked
she said i tell everybody to to do that
nobody ever does it
when i went back to her said i'm
including the story in the book
she said you know i told over a thousand
people over the course of my career
to volunteer on a hotline and only two
people did it and you were one of them
and i thought that's just
that's so obvious
what was that like that suicide hotline
you five months you did that i actually
volunteered there for a total of three
years
and then i got involved in the board and
the funding and the operation and i
taught there too
because i was so into it it was so
valuable um i went there to learn a
skill
and i ended up learning a skill and
serving the community which then was
very no better
secondary bonus
than to do something that benefits you
and have it benefit everybody else too
difficult man uh well if you take the
training you're willing to learn the
training was phenomenal
and i went there to learn so i soaked it
up like a sponge emotionally difficult
uh
it can be depend upon how vulnerable you
make yourself
now since
and what i used to tell the volunteers
there because uh crisis hotline suicide
hotline
the biggest problem is volunteer burnout
it is difficult emotionally if you go
there to help
and you want so much to help
and there's a lot of people that make it
extremely difficult to help them and
that can be emotionally draining
now i went there to learn versus help
and the help was a secondary benefit
so the really difficult types we used to
call them frequent callers
they didn't suck the life out of me they
fascinated me
like this is crazy i gotta learn how to
communicate with these people these are
no different than the people that are
very difficult
in business negotiation because how you
do something is how you do everything
way back when i learned this thing
called the drama triangle
which was kind of three arc archetypes
of difficult people
and we're seeing that show up exactly in
business negotiations
so human behavior is human behavior
period what is that triad well um the
way i learned it way back then was you
know there's there's um uh the victim
uh the protector
and the persecutor
and
someone who comes on a hotline
really portraying themselves as a
victim they're trying to draw you into
being the protector or to give advice
you know i'm i'm i i need your advice
might be what they would literally say
and then if you're dumb enough to give
advice
then they switch from being the victim
to the persecutor and they attack you
for your advice
and then as soon as you back off
then they go back to being a victim
again to try to lure you into giving
them advice so that they can attack your
advice
and so what they told us you know the
earmarks
of watch out for somebody trying to lure
you into giving advice
versus being a great sounding board
helping them
discover
the answer on their own
and then in 2002 much later i run across
jim camp's book start with no
and he talked about effectiveness in
business negotiation
helping your counterpart discover the
best answer because if they discover
something mutually beneficial versus if
you offer it
if they discover it it's their idea and
they're going to do it
if you offer it
you're giving them advice
and they got no emotional ownership and
they're less likely to do it so he
called it helping them discover the best
deal
and back in the on the hotline days it
was just guided discovery helping them
discover the best outcome
from those three years volunteering at
the suicide prevention line was there
anything else that you really learned
about the nature of human beings um that
has stayed with you still to this day in
business and and your days as an fbi
negotiator yeah well you know still
still
still actually going back and and
pulling the lessons out of it um
and it's
you know people are uh
their thoughts are most dominated by
loss
um what are they worried about losing
what's their vision of loss over the
future
daniel kahneman won the nobel prize in
2002
behavioral um
uh
prospect theory uh economic nobel prize
on human behavior which is
lost looms larger than gain
some people are putting it at a two to
one ratio
nobody ever puts it less than two to one
lost things twice as much as a as an
equivalent game i've heard people talk
about be as much as nine to one
which is why researchers are having
trouble putting an exact number on it so
sometimes somewhere between two and nine
times loss
your vision of the loss is going to
determine your behavior
and that was really and we taught on a
hotline and taught in
uh hostage negotiation look for the loss
somebody's taken hostages
they've suffered a personal identity
identity law somewhere along the line
and there's probably a triggering event
in the last 24 to 48 hours but look for
the loss
and then kahneman comes across in 2002
danny kahneman and amos taversky
taversky had died by the time they
awarded the nobel
uh prize which is why he didn't get it
along with kahneman because they're not
giving it after somebody's died
saying that no this is just human
behavior period
period not just hostages not just people
in crisis
but it's the single dominating influence
of all human decision making not the
only
influence
just the biggest
and so learning how to cope with that on
the hotline is exactly what we're doing
these days in all our interactions is
there a way to like leverage that to
your favor when you're negotiating with
someone you can you have to be really
careful with it
which is really
the whole reason
to being use empathy as an approach
because if you don't use empathy
um
then you're the hostage taker
are you trying to use leverage against
them i mean it's it's such a blunt force
trauma concept
that if if you don't do it gently
uh with empathy versus sympathy
you know empathy is is not the same as
sympathy
but you're going to seem like a hostage
taker yourself
if you start out by saying like look man
i know you got a lot to lose if you
don't make this deal
well that's trying to trigger
loss but you yeah i seem like a hostage
taker myself if i do that
so i gotta work my way into a position
where
i gotta get you to
realize
that that's the case
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
when you became a hostage negotiator
when was your first real job
yeah it was a chase manhattan bank
robbery bank robbery yeah with hostages
which
although it happens all you know in the
movies all the time you know bruce
willis
samuel jackson
kevin spacey
eddie murphy they're negotiating the
hostages out of banks and every movie
about it
in real life it's a really rare event
like it was a bank robbery with hostages
in new york city and there hadn't been a
bank robbery with hostages
in new york city for over 20 years
now
people get taken hostage in bank
robberies
but generally the bad guys are gone
before the police show up
because they know if the police get to
play surrounded
their chances of getting away are lou
so they're gonna be gone
but to trap bank robbers in a bank with
hostages really really rare
and that happened about a year and a
half after i got out of the negotiation
training
and i was still volunteering on suicide
hotline so my skills you know you fall
to your highest level of preparation
i was ready i was ready to go when they
put me on the phone because i'd been
negotiations of perishable skill and i'd
been working at it my skill level was
really high at the time are you nervous
when you get that phone call about that
bank robbery
i know i was ready to go i mean
i was doing it because i wanted to
i would want to get involved i wasn't
doing it to get the t-shirt
you know i was doing it because i wanted
to get involved and as a matter of fact
like
i was never asked to go a friend of mine
had taught me
and having made a mistake previously i
had learned the lesson of just show up
if something's going down
show up um
i heard this advice from a government
official not that long ago and he said
run to trouble
always run to trouble
there's a whole bunch of reasons for
that
whether it's business
or law enforcement
one of the nice things about run into
trouble running into you know
figuratively theoretically
running into the burning house
you don't get criticized as much
you know you run the trouble if you're
running into
a static situation or something a bunch
of people have been dealing with for a
while and it's just been sitting there
in deadlock
and whatever you do
people are going to criticize you you
know because they failed and you're
doing something different then they
don't want to see you succeed
but if if you're running that you run
into chaos you run into trouble
you know the criticism is much lower
you know but he's dealing with it
somebody's got to do something decisions
have to be made
it's a great strategy run the trouble
and and i had and i'd come to uh to like
that a lot so
i'm sitting at my desk in new york
my buddy charlie walks up and says
there's a bank robbery with hostages in
brooklyn let's go
i looked at a police detective colleague
because i had an interview scheduled
that morning i said can you cover the
interview
he says yeah i got it and we go
head to the bank and we show up
and a team forms fbi and nypd both show
up because it's a bank
we know the pd negotiators really well
our commander hugh mcgowan super sharp
guy knew what he was doing
he integrated the team first negotiator
on the phone was a pd detective
he points to me says you're the coach
we stood up the rest of the team around
joe the original negotiator
joe talks the situation
into stalemate which is not a bad thing
because the threat level's not coming up
and uh
lieutenant mcgowan looks at me and he
says okay you're up
and they handed me the phone
and what was your job at that point what
was the the the bank robber asking for
and what was your job at your objective
well we didn't know it at the time like
the bank robbery was actually the
classic great ceo negotiator
like the great ceo negotiator is going
to act helpless at the table
because he doesn't want you to force him
into a commitment
you know i found this out some years
later when i was learning negotiation at
harvard
you know they called a business strategy
blame somebody who ain't in the room
so great ceo negotiator is going to be
like look man i got a board of directors
like i got to be careful what i commit
to here because this board of directors
i i you know i do the wrong thing these
guys got to fire me you know they're
going to throw me right out of this
company
and and if the guy does that he's got
all the power in the world he don't care
about his board of directors he just
doesn't want to get backed into a corner
so the bank robbery we get on the phone
with this guy the the the guy who
orchestrated the whole thing
and he's like man i'm scared of these
guys in here these other these other
guys that i'm with man they are
dangerous
like i'm scared of them they might hurt
me
so i gotta be careful what i say to you
oh here they come now
and i gotta hang up the phone and he was
he was making it all up you know
initially
our initial assessment is this guy's an
inadequate personality he's scared to
make a decision
complete smoke screen on his part so
we're you know we're when we're in the
in the negotiation for several hours and
we got the banks surrounded and then the
investigators on the outside
and this is a
residential commercial area of brooklyn
so there are cars everywhere
and they identify the owner of every
vehicle on the outside
and talk to them except there's one van
out there and it belongs to this guy
and as it turns out this guy is running
a cash courier business that services
this bank
and they can't find this guy he is
nowhere to be found
so they go to his address and they say
hey do you know
this guy
and will you come to the scene of the
bank and listen to the voice because
we're running the negotiations on
speaker
outside
to the commanders
and the witness comes in and says yeah
that's that's this guy's name happened
to be chris also
so they voice id this guy and he has
never given us his name this is another
great technique if we meet
and i don't give you my name
[Music]
it unsettles you
you don't feel you've connected with me
and this guy would not give us his name
so you know we're we got a voice id on
him when a lieutenant says you're up
next he says i want you to confront this
guy
about his name as quick as you can
and we're not going to do a normal
smooth hand-off you're just going to
start talking normally the protocol is
if you hand off from one negotiator to
another the second guy comes on he says
look i've been here the whole time
and i've heard of everything that's
going on and here's everything that i've
heard because you don't need the other
guy on the other side saying like
where do i start with this guy you know
have you been here listening do you have
any idea what's going on
it's a smooth transition but a
lieutenant his gut instinct is like yeah
we're not gonna do this this guy's a
manipulative guy
and in a really subtle way
we're going to start taking back control
and we're going to start by not doing a
smooth transition so i get on the phone
i'm talking to this guy now this is a kg
dude
we
shift with no intro
so what does he do
in order to remind us that he's got
hostages but also not raise the threat
level because he's got to genuinely be
concerned that the snipers are going to
put a red dot on his forehead and the
next thing is going to happen is he's
going to be at the pearly gates
explaining his actions over the last 24
hours
he goes and gets a hostage and puts her
on the phone
we haven't we've been there five hours
we had no
confirmation of the condition of the
hostages other than him saying i'm
taking care of the girls everything's
fine as a matter of fact i gotta hang up
the phone cause they're hungry and they
want to get something deep all kinds of
smoke screens
so i'm on a phone and i hear this female
voice come on go like i'm okay i'm okay
and i'm like
uh who's this what's your name i'm okay
and then that's the last i heard of her
he comes back on the phone pretends like
this didn't even happen
i'm like all right this is a cagey dude
we're gonna go forward
i'm gonna find a way to hit him with his
name but do it gently
so i start talking about his van outside
which he knows is out there he just
doesn't know that we've identified it
and i said you know we got a van out
here
and we found
the owners of every van
and spoken to him
except one
and he goes
we have more than one van
now
i got no idea what this guy is talking
about
so i did what we refer to as a mirror i
just repeat the words because my brain
is like what is this guy talking about i
go you have more than one van he goes no
we only have one van i go you you you
only have one van
and he goes
yeah yeah and and you chase my driver
away i go would chase your drive away
he says yeah when he saw the police he
cut and run
now this super control freak guy
is now blurting stuff out
as a result of my mirror my technique
that he did not mean to say
this ends up convicting his getaway
driver who had gotten away and we didn't
even know there was a third guy
how did that case end
everybody came out
why why did the bank robber concede in
the end did he get anything he wanted
well the uh not and you know
and
you know how do you negotiate when
you're not going to give them anything
you know you help them see a different
vision of the future is what it really
boils down to
and what you really want them to see is
a vision of future where they live
and then you're hoping the survival
instinct kicks in
and when the second guy got on the phone
with me
his principal concern was getting killed
right
and his secondary concern
was
uh being handled roughly
when he came out
of course he knew that they had beaten
the women on the inside
and that may contribute to his
being handled roughly when he came out
but he number one didn't want to get
killed and number two
my opening line was look when you when
you come out you'll be treated with
dignity and respect
and i said that to him enough times that
he decided it was going to be true and
uh he asked to meet me face to face out
in front of the bank
was he treated with dignity and respect
a
thousand
you got to keep you got to keep your
promises because
and you know this was this was one of
the things when i was teaching
negotiation at harvard
you know my academic brothers
and sisters up there were like were like
would you lie
to get the guy out
and my answer was no and they'd say like
yeah but let's say let's pretend let's
imagine
that a terrorist has got a nuclear bomb
in boston
and you know that if you lie to him
he won't set the bomb off
so how do you answer that one
and my answer is well number one
the guy's probably testing me to see if
i'll lie
so i gotta watch out that it's not a
trap
number two
if he's not testing me he's gonna be a
better liar than i am
and he's gonna sniff it out you can't
lie to a liar you just can't they're too
good at it
and then number three
even if i lied to him and get them out
somebody's gonna find out that i lied
and i will always have the reputation of
being a liar
and i can't risk my
reputation so if i'm uh if i'm a if i've
got hostages and i call you and i say
listen i want a car i think i saw this
one on your youtube channel i want a car
in 60 seconds outside right
um would you what's the first thing you
say to me you want to try
yeah let's do it all right so i'm the
you're the beggar i'm the bad guy okay
chris
i'm gonna blow this woman's head off if
you don't give me a car in the next 60
seconds
how am i supposed to do that
not my problem you got 55 seconds
all right so if i wanted to do it
it's just it's madness out here it's
chaos i mean this is
ringling brothers barnum bailey circus
is organized compared to the nonsense
that's going on out there so even if i
wanted to do it
i can't do it in that time frame
i'm sure you're the fbi you're the
police you can make anything happen
50 seconds
sounds me like you're not gonna give me
a chance
i'm giving you a chance right now 50
seconds chris there's plenty of cars up
there go get one of the cars and pull it
up outside or i'm going to blow her head
off
sounds like you have a reason to live
i do have a reason to live that's none
of your business
i'm i'm i'm not trying to find out why i
mean
my first number one thing is to make
sure that you live
so get me a car and i will drive off
honestly you've got 45 seconds i don't
want to talk anymore
if you're not gonna give me a chance how
am i supposed to do it i'm giving you a
chance 45 seconds that's plenty of a
chance
like to me even find
get all the commanders together
and get them to think about this
which they're probably not going to do
anyway
i will go and talk to them
about how am i supposed to find them all
talk to them get them to think about it
in 45 seconds okay how long do you need
i know first of all i want you to
understand
i don't think they're gonna do it
well then i'm gonna blow my head off
that would be your choice
see now so the other thing too is
hostage negotiators are successful 93 of
the time
which is one of the things that i
learned in the business which means
seven percent of time they just ain't
coming up
now i we have to do everything we could
possibly do in the meantime
but our number one goal is not putting
any additional people at risk
like i get this question all the time
like if you think it's gonna save a
hostage why don't you just give him a
car
and save those hostages
well i can't put additional people at
risk
and by the way while we were doing that
i don't know anybody put a clock on us
but we went more than 45 seconds it's
true
and what were you thinking when as we
were going through it
um there was
all the questions were
provoking me into all the questions you
asked me
felt like they were dragging me away
from my
objective
in a quite a tactical way so i was
thinking oh he's not this is annoying
he's making me talk and i don't want to
talk
that's kind of what i was thinking and
then
yeah i mean the questions you asked were
making me ponder and they were making me
abandon
my focus which was to just get this car
and kill this woman
right see which was
i wasn't asking you that stuff to get
you to answer what i was really doing
was doing exactly what you talked about
get you to ponder get you to think
you know what kahneman would has talked
about in his book thinking fast and slow
pondering
he would call slow thinking in-depth
thinking where you really think about
stuff
and then you really make the decision
and you really make up your mind instead
of me trying to hustle you
like i could hustle you into something
really quick but it wouldn't be your
decision
and the whole point of getting somebody
to ponder something
is so that when they do come to a
decision they own it
when you said the thing about even if i
wanted to do that
like i couldn't do that in 45 seconds or
whatever
i liked that sentence because it
obviously there was a degree of empathy
there so even if i wanted to it wasn't
you know [ __ ] on my parade it wasn't
attacking me too much
and you made me ponder the reality of
the fact that it's not even possible
my demand is not even possible even if
you
you know were on my side so that was a
very good question to
to make me ponder myself to realize that
what i'm asking for is not going to
happen seeing there's another reason why
i said it like that too um because
you know a lot of people if you ask for
something in a business deal that
they're not going to give you
they give you a classic american lie
i'll try
you know and and
maybe it's not an american line maybe
it's a lie in english language
like but you know in any kind of deal
somebody looks at you and says i'll try
[Music]
you don't get a good feeling no and you
get all trying enough times you know
right away it ain't never happening yeah
yeah so i didn't do i'll try
you know i basically said i don't think
it's gonna happen
but i'll check
because i'm trying to shift
us out of an adversarial into a
collaborative conversation
and so then
what i'm basically saying is like
i don't want to mislead you i don't
think this can happen i will be your
advocate
how important is that collaboration
no relationship survives long term
without collaboration just just ain't
gonna happen
so you're giving me the impression that
you're actually on my side to some
degree and that we're collaborating to
find an outcome together
yeah and point of fact
see the crazy thing is hostage
negotiators have repeat customers
if i get you out alive
the chances of
you straightening out your life
are not great
and the chances of you ending up in
another hostage siege are high
if you don't get killed otherwise
and you got to have a memory of the last
hostage negotiator trying to work with
you
versus the guy hustle jen lied to you
guy or gal
so
if you always look at all interactions
as if you're gonna have to pay for
everything you said eventually
which means if you lie you're gonna pay
for it if you did every thing you could
to be collaborative then your
counterparts going to remember that in
the future like well i didn't go my way
but at least you got in line to me it's
like comma isn't it it's karma a
thousand percent is karma i'm a big
believer in karma very much
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm just going to be
completely honest with you i'm starting
to think a lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together we call
it fitness blockchain and i'm currently
at 81 percent
um so 81 of the days i've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so i'm going
to the gym about six times a week that's
been a little bit impacted by the
derivatio live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it
and so one of the things i'm doing now
to reduce my calorie intake and trying
to get back to being nutritionally
complete and all i eat is i'm having the
hule protein shake thank you for making
a product that i actually like the
salted caramel is my favorite i've got
the banana one here which is the one my
girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
how important is it generally in
negotiations
to listen because a lot of people
you know kind of think they can
overpower someone with right just
talking at them right
yeah and and what they're what they're
called is
um
they can't hold a job yeah yeah
you know you you and there are a lot of
people that are very visible that are
doing that
and in the moment they might look very
good but what ends up happening is
they're frequently initially extremely
successful
and then their success rates drop off a
cliff
and then they don't hold the job because
they were awesome in their first quarter
and it had a continuing steady decline
in their productivity until it went to
zero
and they they can't be tolerated anymore
but everybody sees a really loud guy or
gal
getting deals
or and and they're the ones that make
the most noise about it so your original
question is how as important as
listening
there is
no negotiation methodology that doesn't
list
listening as an advanced skill
no matter what school of thought
somebody's in in
negotiation they all
list listening as advanced
far more difficult
than simply keeping quiet
it's critical
and you will actually end up
increasing the velocity of your deal
cycles by listening
which a lot of people think it's really
counter-intuitive
but you know i did i did an interview
with mark cuban
six or seven months ago and i talked
about listening and he's like yeah you
know if i take the time to to really
hear somebody out in our first deal
and pay attention to what's important
with them
then every deal after that will come to
me faster having done it right up front
and it'll increase the velocity of my
ability to make deals with them because
they'll trust me they'll know that i
hear them out they know that i'm looking
out for them
and consequently
you know
it doesn't take me a long time to
establish trust when we come back we
come to the table we get right down to
it and it really increases the velocity
of my ability to make deals
and a lot of people can't see that
because i got to hear them out i gotta
you know blah blah blah i gotta find out
what their point of view is it seems
highly efficient but what it is is
incredibly efficient long term
and then as it relates to speaking
when you're talking when you were
talking to me then in our little dummy
negotiation
um i noticed the tone of voice you took
was very
very calm
you list in the book three different
voices available
to negotiators right give me a flavor of
those three voices that are available to
negotiators
well there's there's
there's three natural types
um
in humans five fly to make friends and
these are the uh our caveman ancestors
that lived
either fought the saber-tooth tiger
ran from the saber-tooth tiger
or
figured out a way
to
make friends with it
and the indecisive caveman got eaten by
the saber-tooth tiger doesn't have any
descendants
and
we've got substantive reason to believe
that that exists globally regardless of
gender ethnicity
um religion
the three types the globe splitting
pretty evenly into thirds got a lot of
data on it backs it up
our brothers and sisters at harvard
pretty much agree based on their
experience warden has pulled a lot of
the same data comes very very close to
the same
and each type has a voice
you know and the voice of the assertive
natural born assertive which i'm
actually a natural-born assertive
is more the donald trump style
negotiator you know attacking
blunt
direct
you know uh
ivanka trump once described her her dad
donald and said you know he's not blunt
he's just direct
well
he's just an example but you know what i
think is direct you feel like you got
hit in the face with a brick
which is always counterproductive long
term always always always long-term
counterproductive inhibits your ability
to make deals people get tired of
getting hit in the face with a brick
so it wears them out
then there's the very analytical type um
which was you know that soothing calming
voice that i was using
triggers a neurochemical response in you
it actually calms you down
neurochemically it's a involuntary
automatic response now you can fight it
you can fight your way back out of it
but you can't stop me from getting the
calming neurochemicals started in your
head
and you know what if if you're careful
not to seem either cold or condescending
[Music]
that tone of voice is what the great tv
interviewers use the great
news anchors because there's a lot of
there's confidence
and calm simultaneously and people
really like it
and then there's you know there's a
smiling voice a friendly voice and
somebody just smiles when they speak
that triggers a different neurochemical
reaction
the people that you automatically like
right away as soon as soon as you lay
eyes on them as soon as they start
speaking
you know there's an advantage to that
so i was using you know in an emotional
situation and if you're in an emotional
negotiation
you know you want to go with the the
soothing
voice and smile
sprinkle that in
and now you kind of you get the
combination of both of them and it's
it's
collaboration you're going to want to
collaborate with me
if i use that voice
i guess it's an attempt and as you say
to like pacify
pacify them the other thing that i in
chapter three of your book you talk
about is
by the way you got a pretty good voice
you got you got a you got you you're
basically downward inflecting
your voice
portrays
first of all it's very genuine
but it portrays a guy who's actually
really thinking about what he says and
he actually listens oh that's very kind
compliment thank you
but she's still gonna die
in chapter three you talk about um
labeling their pain i found that a
really interesting concept right don't
feel their pain label it i think that's
probably a mistake i've been making i
actually was thinking about that in the
context of like my romantic
relationships right when my girlfriend
is talking at me as a way to kind of
create that bridge
how do i
create that bridge by acknowledging or
labeling her pain can you explain to me
what you mean by labeling their pain
you know um think of what whatever the
negative emotion that they're feeling is
the elephant in the room so if i'm if
i'm
you know i'm holding someone hostage and
i'm crying
yeah
yeah i'm gonna say
it sounds like you feel like you're out
of control
it sounds like you
you feel that
you're gonna have to do something you
really don't want to do
and what does that do to me when you
when you do that
all right so and this is one of the few
and the black swan method that's also
backed up by neuroscience like we know
anecdotally that this stuff works
because we're proving it over and over
again we're walking the talk
we make our own deals
very effectively
and the people that we coach make their
deals and accelerate their deals very
effectively so you know so we got no
shortage of our own anecdotal
information we don't really don't need
the neuroscience
but there's been several neuroscience
experiments
they put people in fmri's functional
magnetic resonance imaging devices where
they can watch the brain light up
and they induce
negative feelings in people and they
watch
the brain light up
typically by showing them some sort of
photograph
that causes them to feel a negative
emotion whether it's sadness anger
whatever it is
and then they simply ask the people to
identify
or label
what they're feeling as a result of the
what they saw
[Music]
and each and every time the person
labeled it
the the uh
electrical activity in that part of the
brain diminished every time
not deny
but just called it out you know you
don't deny the elephants in a room you
say there's an elephant a room and that
makes people feel
heard or seen or felt all of the all of
the above right so you know whatever the
emotional reaction to that is people
feel seen
heard felt understood
and it's probably a combination of you
know the emotional reaction and the
neuroscience reaction is it diminishes
the negative emotions
every time now the degree the degree
that it diminishes the emotions changes
like i you know we call that a label and
i may label the negative that that i
hear
and it might have a minimal impact a
tiny little impact or might have a huge
impact
but the impact is the type of impact is
the same every single time the degree of
impact changes but the nature of the
impact
is always to diminish the negative
emotion
one of the things that i read as well
that you're looking for in these
negotiations is for
them to conf give you a confirmation
like if they say that's right yeah so
you're you're trying to get me to not
blow this lady's head off and if you can
get me to say
that's right
what is that a signal of that's right is
what people say when they feel
understood you pull that's right out of
somebody
you're on your way in
in the direction of a great resolution
no matter what the negotiation landlord
tenant
employee employer
you know business deal
pulling that's rights
sends you in a great direction so you've
labeled something that i'm feeling you
said stephen it feels like you're about
to do something you don't want to do and
then i go that's right right now so
so tall
rise great researcher besides great
author
he speculates he says you know i think
somebody says that's right when they
even experienced an epiphany to some
degree
that's what you say when you when you
what you think you've heard is
completely true you're not agreeing with
a person
you're observing that what they said was
true
and when he said epiphany i'm like ah
this is interesting let me look up the
neuroscience of epiphanies
and among the neural chemicals that you
get ahead of
in an epiphany is oxytocin
which is the bonding drug so you get a
hit of oxytocin based on what i've said
and you have an involuntarily
feeling of bonding towards me
and then
you know the neuroscientists that i
think the world of andrew huberman
i heard him talking about on oxytocin
and he says that oxytocin tends to make
people tell the truth
so if you say that's right
you're going to feel bonded to me and
you're going to be more likely to tell
me the truth
that ain't a bad position for me to be
in in a negotiation
negotiations are you know
all over our lives so i mean
yeah when i was everywhere everywhere
right it's everything it's teams it's
business it's podcasting it's my
girlfriend whatever when i was reading
through the the principles in your book
never split the difference
um
so much of it i could relate to you from
the context of like romantic
relationships with my partner yep you
must find yourself in your own romantic
relationships deploying some of these
skills
and which ones of them
which one in terms of whether it's just
you know acknowledging them making them
feel heard what are the key skills that
translate really effectively to romantic
relationships
well they all do
because every human being wants to be
understood
and in a romantic relationship
they want to know that you understand
you know and in many cases
like any relationship
they just need need that in and of
itself now the additional demands of
romantic relationship is
they're gonna want you to understand and
adjust
which in point of fact
what other relationship
do they not want that from you as well
not only show me you understand
but
then walk the talk
it's um
the closer you are to someone
sometimes
you just it's really harder for you to
see things from their perspective
like you think you didn't do anything
wrong and you know and
typically male female but not confined
to this
you thought you were fine when in fact
what they perceived was that you were
clumsy and
insensitive are you good at negotiating
in
a romantic relationship because i can
i'll ask her when
well the problem with dating a really
smart girl is
she starts out negotiating you pretty
quickly
but the really that you know the real
issue is
what's your intent behind it
like if you're hearing your romantic
partner out just to get him to shut up
like the second or third time you pulled
that on them they have figured it out
and you're disingenuous
but if you're hearing somebody out
because you want things to be better
you really want
the relationship to be long-term and you
want it to continue to get better
then they're happy to
let you hear them out or to be
let you make them feel heard
because you're going to make the
adjustments and your behavior to take
that into account and you're going to
show that you care enough about how they
feel
not just what happened but how they feel
about what happened which is a recipe
for a great relationship romantic or not
but as as should be
it's even a higher standard for a
romantic relationship because how can
you be
involved long-term if you don't care how
the other person feels
in your negotiation negotiating days was
there an instance where
it really didn't go the way you wanted
it to go yeah and with 93 success rate
means seven percent of time is going bad
and that's just that's just the nature
of the game is there one that stands out
for you as being well every one of them
does
but
then then the issue is do you learn
like uh naseem nicholas taleb would call
it post-traumatic stress
growth like you go through a traumatic
event
um are you traumatized by it which and
then damaged and never recover
post-traumatic stress
uh injury harm disorder
or is there post-traumatic stress growth
where you took that and decided to be
better than you ever were before because
you never
want to let that happen again
when i said when i say this what is the
incident that comes to mind well the
first one uh that people died in
was the second case that i worked in the
philippines the burnham's a barrel case
and
early on before we could even get our
arms around
like a situation that was
moving really fast and the philippine
military was engaged and chasing the bad
guys
and a chase had been on for weeks
um guaranteero was murdered uh by by the
abu sayyaf
about 21 days into that case they had
already killed a number of filipinos
prior to that
and as they moved across the landscape
and the oceanscape and island island
south of philippines
they would they would kill hostages and
pick up new hostages because there were
people in their way all the time
so that was an ugly case from the
beginning to the end
in the end of it
uh
the two of the three remaining hostages
were killed in a botched rescue attempt
and they were shot by friendly fire
philippine scout rangers
inadvertently stumbled over the abu
sayyaf encampment
didn't realize it was one that had
hostages and it just opened fire
they recognized it as a terrorist
encampment
formed a skirmish line on the trees on
the uphill side and just started pouring
um rifle fire down into the camp
uh and so that was
that was the first time that i'd worked
anything where people had gotten killed
does that stay with you yeah it does it
does and and i felt sorry for myself for
a long time and it's not like i'm um i'm
happy about it but
for i'll never remember the moment that
i got the call 5 30 in the morning i was
in washington dc
where i lived
and a voice on the other end of the
phone said i've got bad news martin is
dead
and it was just a few hours after martin
burnham
had been killed and deborah yap the
filipino hostage been killed martin's
wife gracia
was wounded and lived
and i i'll never forget that was the
worst
that to that point and since
was the worst
professional moment personal moment of
my professional career and i used to say
is the worst moment of my personal
career until i was hearing another
hostage negotiator talking about a siege
he was in
when
an infant had
had died had been killed
and i remember sitting there watching
him talk about it and he's still very
definitely
dealing with the scars and the wounds
from having been the negotiator on scene
and i remember him saying like you know
i don't know why i keep telling you know
giving these presentations maybe i just
want people to know something
bad that happened to me on a winter's
day
and i was sitting there thinking
bad for you
that wasn't your blood it wasn't your
child
and i thought you know
we're taking on too much
because it wasn't a member of our family
it wasn't my brother
wasn't my significant other it wasn't my
son i got killed
and that's when i tried to that's when i
realized i had to put that stuff in
perspective it wasn't doing anybody any
good
for me feeling sorry for myself
i couldn't and and
what we the changes we made as a result
of the pronunciation saved lives
you know that was that was our mandate
all right so martin burnham is dead
what do we do with that
do we quit or do we get better
if we get better
somebody else is going to live and a
whole bunch of people ended up living
based on
strategy adjustments we made as a result
of that case it seems like a big
a very significant sort of burden to
carry right it goes back to what i said
at the start you know it takes a certain
type of person to want to be
want to play with those stakes yeah
somebody who's naive
yeah you just don't know any better
makes us difficult sometimes just
thinking about you know the traumatic
things we go through it makes us much
difficult especially in forming
relationships
i was i struggled with that a lot
struggled in
having a girlfriend probably because my
home life was so traumatic that i would
always run from commitment but when
you've lived in such and you hear the
same with like soldiers and stuff you
know and you've lived through such sort
of traumatic events
and high stakes
coming home to
hey babe you're right can be
difficult right yeah yeah it can be it
can be it can be difficult you can you
can have difficulty unwinding
the other person depending on how you
process information
like the other person might genuinely
doing their best to be there with you to
get you to talk about it
and
you know if you if if that isn't the
best way that you process it
and yeah one of the very difficult
things about me is
i don't process stuff by talking about
it i'll talk about it afterwards
you know but i i kind of need i need to
unplug you know i'll need a good night's
sleep
you know i'll need i'll need to let it
run through the data banks and kind of
bake on its own i'm probably pretty good
the next day which is interesting
because in your work you have no time
for that
yeah well you know and maybe that's why
i need it more at home because in the
work i mean we're gonna
you know we're going on it right now
we're dealing with it right now
mirroring something you talk about as
well in the book which i find really
interesting because again something with
my girlfriend i started to explore which
was
you know when she says something to me
or when she does something i to make her
again feel hurt i guess i just kind of
repeat it back to her right also trying
to is it also a body language thing or
is it just
how does mirroring mirroring work well
the hostage negotiators mirror the black
swans mirror you know the way that we
teach in business now just all verbal
okay you know if if you start lining up
physically
uh which is what the body language
mirroring thing is
like if you if you if that happens
naturally then so be it
enough people try to do it as a
manipulative tool
that we're really leery of
even coaching people on that at all like
if we're talking and suddenly we both
find us and i'm actually listening and
you're listening we both find ourselves
leaning the same direction that's cool
because we're dialed in
but the body language thing is is a tool
of manipulation so many times of people
that are just trying to exploit you
that aspect of it we stay away from now
the hostage negotiated mayor the black
swan mirror
repeating just the last one or three
words of what somebody said or then
taken surgically
picking a gist one or three words here
and there it's ridiculously effective
ridiculously effective yeah
you did very nice
just and and the thing that i find
fascinating about it too is
like if we find somebody that's really
into mirroring
they'll typically be somebody who's iq
and eq both are real high
and there are a lot of people whose iq
is real high
you know their book smarts are good but
the people smarts aren't good
and they tend to love mirroring because
it's
the least amount of effort with the
maximum amount of response
and they want to
guide and negotiation
in a very gentle but purposeful way
while the and the other side doesn't
feel guided they feel like they're
expanding
and it's been real consistent when you
think about your your next phase and
your next your projects that you're
working on now and what you're trying to
do you've got your the blacks one group
right i saw that online um the objective
of that is to to coach people into
negotiation skills and stuff like that
yeah worldwide globally
yeah and what does that look like is it
a course that people can buy is it a
webinar what is it yeah it's all of it
the website is blackswanltd.com
i mean if you just start now we got free
stuff
like how do you start to get better now
if you're further on down the line
we coach people through
all kinds of deals
on a regular basis and it's a really big
part of what the company does we coach a
lot of people
through negotiations
and you've got your book as well which
we've talked about a bit which is never
split the difference which has sold more
than two million copies worldwide which
is just staggering
crazy crazy numbers we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the
previous guest leaves a question for the
next guest oh and i get to
i only get to see when i open the book
okay oh good handwriting so this is
useful
okay
is there someone
in your life
that really needs your help
but you are still unsure
on how to help them
uh there's uh there's someone in in my
immediate family
that um
i can uh i continue to
buy the wrong gifts for
and uh
i've got actually a conversation
scheduled
for me to at least say all right i
realize i'm getting it wrong
help me get it right
i think we can all relate to that in
some respects well i can anyway
thank you chris thank you for your time
thank you for writing such a great book
on a topic that is relevant to more than
just fbi negotiations as you know it's
relevant to my relationship with my
partner to my business to everything in
between it's really relevant to all the
interactions i have with all humans and
that's clearly a testament to why it's
sold more than it's almost 2.5 million
copies or something crazy like that
i know that i know the stats around
books i know that more
i think my publisher told me that
most books don't sell a thousand copies
so like 90 plus percent of books don't
sell a thousand copies just so to sell
2.5 million copies worldwide is
staggering but it speaks to your
experience and and the way you
articulated it in the book it's been an
honor to speak to you thanks for your
wisdom
and um i'm going to keep brushing up my
negotiation skills pleasure's been mine
thanks for having me on thanks chris
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as we all know
energy independence and living a little
greener has never been more important
for a better future it's a journey i've
been on over the last couple of years
that i've shared with you sporadically
ever since i sold my range rover sport
and bought an electric bicycle and
there's a lot of people out there that
listen to this podcast that are looking
to make that sustainable switch in
the things that run their daily life
whether it's their home their car their
vehicles whatever it might be so when a
good friend of mine at a company called
my energy called jordan
told me she was interested in sponsoring
this podcast i jumped at the opportunity
so for those of you that don't know my
energy are a uk renewable energy brand
whose mission is to increase the usage
of green energy helping people like you
and i to save time and money when it
comes to making sustainable switches in
our lives so if this resonates with you
and you're the type of person that's
been looking or thinking about going on
your own sustainability journey i highly
recommend checking them out at
myenergy.com
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]